today we're having some sexy yeah what
qualifies a drink as sexy something with
a really velvety mouthfeel hopefully
they're gonna be like an aphrodisiac and
they actually start like getting our
juices going yeah put the [ __ ] back in
cocktail baby
oh we're gonna put our dicks in the
drinks too this is sex on the beach
oh this is the most classic of the sexy
drinks this Beach really needs some
cleanup this is the one they order in
movies where it's the lady at the bar
she goes I'll have a sex on the beach
it's great this reminds me of spring
break I mean it's kind of giving me a
boner
actually alcohol usually gets you less
of it don't you think it's like the
fruit that's having sex in the drink
girl I put the cran and yo Barry mmm I
also put my dick in the drink this is
very sugary which means it would give
you a really bad hangover so like real
sex on the beach you're gonna enjoy it
in the moment regret it the morning
after oh yeah that's a UTI yeah had sex
on the beach
no no really like what do you mean
really no what is this beautiful look at
that contour a girl look at that
highlight and contour it looks like a
[ __ ] did you put your sex inside my
drink Eugene buttery nipple this is
called a buttery nipple dude just like
in this yeah no I know I know I know
yeah I know I've tasted nipples it's
called buttery because it's butterscotch
liqueur actually oh that tastes just
like grandma well it's like grandma's
Bowl does this make you want to have sex
I'll answer it for you yes it does this
is the best-tasting nipple I've ever had
I just keep thinking about how your
grandma
that's why my grandma was hot yo suck
bang and blow
sounds like a good Tuesday nothing
pretty cool pretty cool yeah I feel like
you would stop begging
Wow Chuck bang blow you gotta suck it
nice mmm that's awful what's this flavor
I don't know oh let me try that my
friend is a lot of different liquor this
drink will get you [ __ ] yeah like when
you have a sex a different way for the
first time you're like I don't know what
this is oh well this is weird
any of the sexy drinks this is the drink
that's like I'm ready to [ __ ] tonight
and I don't care who how many photos you
give it bro Wow well I would order this
if I if I didn't love myself well I'm
gonna do boner and a half right here not
to shade y'all Floridians fit y'all
definitely Oh Florida definitely dresses
this Chelsea would wears Kelsey Darcy oh
this is this ring is Kelsey bar
Kelsey what do you think of that joke
what is this
Oh [ __ ] shot so what does that mean
that it's a [ __ ]
is there a reason our dicks are pointed
to each other you have to take this
without your hands what if we each like
I'll go to the right you go to the left
what a goofy shaped wiener
Gina I notice that yours is dirtier than
mine Rock Paper Scissors shoot
means I suck your dick first time for
everything
yeah
[Music]
and the ever you got the phone one your
mouth I can't swallow with my teeth
around a big table you know I'm saying
do it something on the face a classic
got milk moment thank you dude it I
barely feel my mouth around it oh yeah
I'm blowing your job just take the drink
SEC don't think about it too much so
thank you this is too wide for my mouth
like how do you swallow oh you're my
finger huh bigger oh that's why I was I
was suffering figuring out how you
swallow it
oh don't throw it up your how'd you
swallowing your mouths open I don't know
is it in back back back it's the worst
[ __ ] I've ever gotten
[Music]
I was there for you that's good how's it
for you it's pretty good you know
sweeter than I my wife sneakers are
ruined how do I exit this segment now
[Music]
time to end with the six list of all
drinks the body place in the shot no I
know it goes in his belly button that's
why that's why it's sexy
well I'll go where there seems to be a
least amount of hair which is your
delightful neck I've always been a thigh
guy that's too much salt you eat no he
needs more
he needs more it doesn't get deeper it's
going to start level I'm gonna have wet
underwear all day ranks Ned did you
floss this morning I who fought us in
the morning he's making a joke feel the
rhyme
[Music]
[Music]
that wasn't turned on by it but I wasn't
turned off by what have we learned today
I learned that drinks aren't sexy it's
the people who drink them that are sexy
huh that's sweet yeah how'd you make
this so sweet to Zach's tiny [ __ ]
body is why you never spit thanks for
watching this video if you liked this
and you want to see more bigger crazy
fantastic stuff watch squad wars you can
get it for 30 days for free if you wait
until March you can watch the whole
thing and pay nothing this week we've
got two of our favorites the Dudesons
burst fun house and a news challenge
it's some more exciting than it sounds
also I get hit in the nuts a ton and I
might not be able to have children
anymore
was that good